هذا هذه المنطقه هي المنطقه التي تشهد
قتال داري حتى الان ويمكنكم سماع ادويه
اطلاق النار والاشتباكات والطلقات التي
يعني تطلق من فتره الى اخرى في هذه
المنطقه وايضا كل ما كان هناك حركه
للطيران يحلق من سماء هذا المكان تزداد
وتيره الضربات ربما هي يعني مضادات ارضيه
للطيران او ربما تحاول ابعاد هذه الطائرات
من هذه المواقع هذا يعني هذه المنطقه التي
نحن حول هي المنطقه التي يشتد فيها القتال
بشكل شرس منذ ساعات الصباح وحتى الان
نعم وما زلنا نتابع هذه الصور من العاصمه
الخرطوم لهذا الدخان الكثيف الذي لم يتوقف
منذ اندلاع هذه المواجهه امس
ونستمع في الوقت نفسه الى اطلاق النار
المستمر ايضا والذي يهدا تاره ويعود بشده
تاره اخرى